well it's harder to be funny than it is
to be um to move people emotionally
although humor is an emotion as well
because some people have it's it's
always easier to make somebody cry than
laughs I thought you know and so when
you're trying to use humor in
advertising what you look for is the
unexpected but it has to be relevant to
the brand to the personality of the
brand and to the product you're selling
and it has to be meaningful to the
consumer as well you just can't do humor
for the sake of being funny and not have
it connect to anything because then
you're just using the clients money to
be you know a jokester and that nobody
likes that very much they don't they
usually frown on that but if you can
connect the humor to what is important
about the brand of what you want people
to remember you know then it's good I
mean all we try to do in advertising is
help the consumer fall in love and we
want them to fall in love with the brand
and we want them to find value in the
product and that's we used everything
humor dogs kids celebrities whatever we
can think of to help the consumer or to
motivate that consumer to fall in love
it's all about love you know that's
really the big overriding emotion
you